und jetzt wird sich 17 prozent egal wenn
ich irgend ein mädel meinen arien und
steckte es wahrscheinlich geil hier ein
video heute was geht ich hoffe es jetzt
gut erstmal muss ich sagen es tut mir
leid ist kann es längere zeit nicht ich
war nämlich die letzten vier tage im
urlaub bin ein bisschen braun geworden
also ich finde ich sie echt aus wie ein
anderer mensch was die bäume angeht
ich weiß gar nichts verändert ist seit
egal auf jeden fall kommt jetzt neues
video
mir hat nämlich setzen abonnent von mir
bei instagram joana ich hab da so eine f
entdeckt test jedoch macht dies mehr
cool da geht's nämlich ums küssen und
ich habe mir gedacht ja kommen warum
nicht macht dazu doch einfach mal im
video und zwar ist dass die app ist
davon gab es allerdings drei
verschiedene es deswegen habe ich jetzt
drei verschiedene apps auf mein handy
also was das küssen angeht bin ich echt
glaube ich richtig gut ich habe schon
von über 2 300 mädels gehört das war der
beste kurs meines lebens vielleicht
nicht also das weiß ein bisschen überall
so natürlich nicht zwei oder drei 100
aber ich bin auf jeden fall sehr
gespannt ob das ganze funktioniert und
ob ich ein guter küsser bin
wir fangen sie es dort mal an ich will
gar nicht sagen aber auch wenn sie jetzt
wahrscheinlich schon wieder eine minute
lang ist im video okay ist jetzt der
eigenwillige ritter kissing kissing test
und kist meter ich frage mich wer
erfindet sonne scheiße und wird sagen
wir fangen einfach mal mit der ersten
app an und weiß das klingt es jörg peter
kruse also bis zum guter küsser test
oder findet heraus wer sein geschlecht
und fang an so ich bin auf jeden fall
ein female wattenbek nicht so und ich
weiß nicht aber ich glaube ich musste
ihr alter auf dem handy bällchen sind
schon viele bakterien
ach du scheiße analyzing kurz mit
analysiert das schneide ich jetzt am
besten raus schulmädchen look ist wie
ein kleines mitteln ist es sein erster
coup nein ist es nicht mal dass es
locker mein 5000 nochmal so mail wartet
[Musik]
analysiert veterans of plenty of
experience pack angeles zusammen lässt
so ist für mich aus nur einmal versuchen
wir noch kurz darauf dass du dein bild
spricht ohne spaß ich habe so das gefühl
da kommt einfach immer irgendwas egal
wie du küsst
da kommt halt das ist ein zufallsprinzip
deswegen ich probier's einfach mal
female und ich klasse mit meiner hand
hier drauf spaghetti das ist ein
bisschen gruselig die also dass keines
gary wang yue keine ahnung hat das wort
noch nie grad ok einmal auch ganz prima
in schöner kurs vom 8
er leistet laut zwei nato fa cups green
egal also die app ist auf jeden fall
schon mal okay jetzt setzt man die
zweite app und weiters auch kiß epp das
ganze wieder so aus ok ich muss kurz
meinen mund bisschen an feuchten
[Musik]
13% romantisch 2% erfahrung und 15
prozent
das ist überhaupt passion hat einfach
die passion aber ist klar ist das kann
doch nicht sein dass wir doch so gut du
einmal noch das gute ist alle die dieses
video sehen werden von meinen freunden
ihr werdet nie mehr einfach so mein
handy in die hand nehmen was ist das in
der scheiße prozent romantik mit du
nicht verraten
das ist das ist der absolute rods ich
habe es ja in meiner nase gemacht und
jetzt plötzlich 17% roman feger wenn ich
gegen meinen arien und steckte es
wahrscheinlich geil hier also die hat
würde ich mir niemals hole dann holt
euch lieber den ersten kipping lässt
also diese app ist der absolute
möglichkeit gern noch mal einfach mein
ohr dran halten
funktioniert alles klar
11% romantiker ich frage mich das kann
doch nicht sein oder wartet mal ganz
ehrlich
verpiss dich du jetzt versuchen wir
jetzt matthias meter
okay ich bin mega nervös muss
runterkommen durch 21 prozent roman 65
das ist eigentlich auch so gut noch mal
13 prozent
ich finde ich ein bisschen gemein muss
ich ehrlich sagen okay letzter versuch
nochmal
[Musik]
letztere 6 prozent es kann doch nicht
sein das kann einfach nicht sein und
spaß ist kann ich doch nicht hochladen
oder leute passt auch das nächste girl
dass ich küsse
das muss in meiner skepsis soll bewerten
wie der kurs war
ich weiß zwar nicht ob sie das mitmacht
aber man kann es ja mal versuchen bei
12.000 like sooo viel daten ich auch
dass ihr euch mitten unter alten checkt
auf jeden fall intrigen und netze ab und
wir sehen uns dann morgen wieder morgens
gutes video und york v3 genießt das
schöne wetter